President Trump is turning his focus to
school safety he visited victims at a
Florida hospital Friday this Wednesday
the president will hold a listening
session with high school students and
teachers and on Thursday he will meet
with state and local leaders on school
safety mr. Trump lashed out at the FBI
during the weekend tweet storm
he wrote very sad the FBI missed all of
the many signals sent out by the Florida
school shooter they are spending too
much time trying to prove Russian
collusion with the Trump campaign there
is no collusion Errol Barnett is
traveling with the president and joins
us from West Palm Beach
Erol good morning good morning on
Twitter President Trump seemed to be
attacking everyone but Russia which the
special counsels office has accused of
information warfare against the United
States but it was mr. Trump's comments
about the FBI and the school shooting
here in South Florida that got most
people's attention the reality of it is
that they are two separate issues the
president should be staying out of law
enforcement business Republicans
responded to president Trump's criticism
of the FBI after he seemed to link the
parklands shooting with the Russia probe
in a flurry of tweets the president
criticized Democrats for using Russia as
an election excuse he called claims of
campaign collusion a hoax and said that
the Russia investigations were creating
chaos in the u.s. Russia's clearly tried
to advance their agenda into the United
States
the president's outburst followed
special counsel Robert mullahs
indictment Friday against 13 Russians
for using social media to disrupt the US
election as you can see with the FBI
indictment the evidence is now really
incontrovertible the president's
national security adviser HR McMaster
applauded mullahs efforts but president
Trump's shot back at his aide online
saying quote general McMaster forgot to
say that the results of the 2016
election were not impacted or changed by
the Russians now we should be clear
mullahs charges made no judgment on
whether Russian intervention swung the
election but it did say Russia's efforts
were designed to bolster mr. Trump's
candidacy
Gail thank you very much Errol